hallo mein name ist lucanet ich will
kommen heute zu einem neuen video ich
habe mir gedacht ich zocke heute mal
wieder call of duty black ops buyvip
newtown ich weiß das ist nicht das
neueste cod oder ich kann mich nicht so
richtig aus der kompletten cod reihe ich
weiß nicht ob die mp 7 sowie ich dir mit
dem radar dings drauf habe ob das eine
gute waffe ist ich falls ich bin nicht
gut in schuss
ich weiß ich bin ich der beste spieler
ich hab' ich habe verloren tatsächlich
ich bin die aufnahme geht eine minute
ist stark wenigstens kann ich sagen dass
ich das spiel beendet habe ohne einmal
gestorben zu sein aber ich habe dagegen
auch noch einen kirchen freunde das auch
immer wieder schöne guck mal das
statisch karten video kommende runde ein
denk mir richtig tolle newtown die
webcams sogar und alles vorbei aber ich
würde sagen wir hängen wir noch eine
runde dran
die map sieht ja richtig toll aus ich
glaube wieder mit meiner mp 7 rum und
ich glaube von da könnten gegner kommen
oh mein gott ich hab sogar jemand
getroffen ok granaten daher nochmal eine
bombe
oh mein gott ich hab mir natürlich okay
wie schlecht war das bitte wie schlecht
war das kann mir dass irgendein cod
spieler mal beantworten eigentlich
wollte ich in dem video darüber reden
dass imo bin ich hier kann ich auch in
diesem video wollte ich eigentlich
darüber reden das war warum wohl die
balu
oh mein gott ich bin schon wieder ein
kind ich laufe hier rum wie der letzte
spaß haben überhaupt keine ahnung wie
das ganze irgendwie funktioniert weiß
auch leerlauf überhaupt habe ich mir
schon wieder ich bin erster heute bei
allem respekt zone also ich weiß die
wahrscheinlich sagen wir alle so luca
auch sein
du warst schlecht habe ich nie gekommen
ich das jetzt im vorlauf du sollst
versuchskaninchen ich warte jetzt hier
auf den typen bisher in der pistole apa
dass ich wollte eigentlich über ein
thema reden
aber warum wo coulibaly vitello und so
sind wie soll ich nicht mehr meinen
videos im hintergrund sind aber in
diesem spiel es geht ja wirklich nur
darum freigeschaltet viel abfall
wasserretter was bin ich denke hier
alles vergeltung in dem spiel geht
verrät ich die ganze zeit drunter und
drüber alter ich habe ja überhaupt keine
ahnung wo ich irgendwie hin laufen muss
hier die überall kommen die ganze zeit
gegner um richtig richtig kritisch hier
hier oben kann man chillen und das macht
man hier kann man hieraus guck mal und
ist ein kumpel von mir der joshua
menschen tötete und auch nicht hier
kommen doch locker genau da kommt er
dann gehe ich mal wieder hier ans
fenster und sehe das ja hier ist
tatsächlich irgendwie gerade niemand
wenig von nach vorne malaga ist einer
ich habe getroffen
oh mein gott doppel ich bin erster
freunde ich bin der dümmste cod spieler
aller zeiten wie kann es sein dass ich
so viele kills machen wahrscheinlich
helfen mich gerade alle oder wir kommen
gleich locker noch einer hoch irgendwie
der tötet ihn ersten ich warte bis
meiner tod ist auch meine hatten kiel
gemacht denn wenig munition okay war
meine zweite waffe ist ein messer das
ist super nein damit ist scheiße ich hab
mal 82 kg das ist für mich echt gut also
was ist denn das was ist denn was zum
pick ist da passiert also was ich
eigentlich sagen wollte ich wohl nie
vitello balu und die ganze gang
eigentlich ist die bei mir irgendwie im
hintergrund steht deswegen jetzt mal
ohne 4 run suchen hier luca ich weiß im
schnitt denkst wir gerade 8 luca wie du
sagst du im video nicht mit vier runs
das ist meine technik habe ich bock
drauf das ganze so zuschneiden ich weiß
auch jetzt hab ich ja aber jetzt kann
ich ja gar nix mehr ich habe in meinem
klarnamen übrigens irgendwie kaffee
steht ich weiß nicht warum
irgendwie ich hatte glaube ich damals
keinen bock auf den landtag oder so der
think aber ich habe keine ahnung fragt
mich nicht ich schnüffelt richtig dass
von hier gleich einer kommt oder von
hier irgendwo von von irgendeiner
richtung hier vorne irgendwo will nicht
von irgendwo oder von will von hier
vielleicht einer com oder so da da ist
auch einer da ist einer drin das hab ich
gesehen das habe ich gesehen habe ich
gesehen genau du bist tot genauso kopf
genau da kommt ein und ich krieg ihn
nicht weg ich wollte euch sagen freunde
wo vitello hier vitello und wo balu hier
ist balu und wo ach guck mal diese
skizzen hier das o mein gott da stehe
ich einfach nur jünger kacke und da
kommt so ein typ und die
aber es hat er gut gemacht tatsächlich
sind bei mir keine sorge ich habe die
nicht entsorgt da haben ja viele gesagt
so ja okay die gibt's nicht mehr diesem
tod oder wie wilde wasser wie soll eine
wasserflasche und stofftieren sterben
freunde also wirklich jetzt mal was toll
danke die runde fing an mit irgendwie
acht zu eins oder sohn jetzt habe ich
neun zu sechs das ist ja nur noch
traurig da sind welche das sind doch
safe welche 3 60 meter was die leute
sagen ich war
wenn ich krank bin ich als spieler haben
guck mal anstatt die wechsel haben
allerdings die täler und balu sind auf
jeden fall bei mir ukulele ist weg weil
habt ihr habt vielleicht ukulele block 2
gesehen der gibt es auf meinem kanal zu
sehen also schaut einfach olenicoff 2
das war eines der letzten videos nicht
hochladen hat er kommt hier aus der
konzern 4 aus an der schwelle zu kühl
gewesen die ukulele war bei marvin also
weil ja und kollegen block 2 gedreht
wurde auch co man sehr sehr schöner
enkel jonas aber er war schon am
kempener ecke und vitello und balladen
wirklich einfach in seiner schublade bei
mir hier unten drin muss ich ehrlich
gesagt zu geben weil die sache ist ja
auch endlich die hier hinstellen würde
so das wird gar keinen sinn mehr ergeben
weil die idee seht ihr ja nur wenn er
hier stehen würde das ist nicht auf
meinem tisch tatsächlich deswegen waren
die beiden hat nicht da war halt auch
nicht weil nintendogs bei mir irgendwie
letzter zeit nicht richtig läuft
deswegen steht ihr einfach nichts im
hintergrund und es ist einfach so ein
bisschen kleiner geworden die lad merkt
geschrieben luca wir vermissen die uns
so und blei aber ja das ist auf jeden
fall der grund wieso nicht da sind also
kollege hatte ich abgegeben
zur produktion von den kollegen blogs
also die hab ich nicht abgegeben so die
kommt bald wieder und diese beiden waren
einfach die ganze zeit da nur allerdings
habe ich in letzter zeit weniger videos
hochladen von akinator clever bord und
so aber freuen wenn ihr dann wieder
wollt so ein bisschen mehr akinator
klemm aber dann schreibt mir mal ideen
dafür die kommentare weil ich kann nicht
jemanden jeder akinator folge so meine
mich selbst und meine leute hier google
das ist ja irgendwann auch langweile
dieses kissen hier kommt am 17 06 in den
terminen statt
da könnt ihr am 17.6 das ist ein freitag
ab 17 uhr bestellen da gibt es auch neue
t-shirts das könnt ihr dann ab 17 uhr
kaufen also schlecht er schon mal den 17
6 in den kalender und da gibt es auch
wieder autogrammkarten dazu also wenn
ihr einen sticker unterschrieben von mir
haben wollte es gibt wirklich nur wenige
tausend stück oder sowie waren letztes
mal innerhalb von kürzester zeit weg
notierte solchen kalender 17 36 darin
luca shop kommt das rein und das war
eigentlich das worüber ich reden wollte
also warum die nicht mehr mit und stand
einfach weil die formate nicht haben und
weil ich das ein bisschen kleiner jahren
wollten weil politik nicht da war und so
weiter und so fort
das was ihr vom video ich wollte einfach
nur ein cod gameplay nutzen um so ein
bisschen darüber zu reden oder da ist
mir aufgefallen die ganzen leute die
kommentares machen nehmen das gameplay
ja vorher auch wo sie sich konzentrieren
und reden dann wo sie sich konzentrieren
ich habe beides vermischt und hat mich
überhaupt nicht konzentriert das war ein
bisschen blöd wenn es euch trotzdem
irgendwie unterhalten konnte freue ich
mich über eine bewertung und wir sehen
uns in den nächsten